for breakfast in the botanical garden
there's cake the kind farmers wives and
Southern Denmark used to make
loads of cream and butter go into it the
farmers would have quickly burned off
the calories working in the fields now
the sumptuous sweets from the soda Bach
region are known far beyond the borders
of Denmark I think I've already tried oh
all of them and yeah 14 kinds of cakes
today those not in the mood for sweets
can try smoked cow's milk cheese or many
other specialties offer here by more
than 50 Nordic restaurants and food
producers
150 events packed into 10 days are
taking place all around copenhagen
celebrating social food
the social food concept has some
different dimensions one of them is the
meeting with other people around tables
another one is social awareness that's a
lot of focus about it simply waste food
wastes today the chef's here used local
produce as much as they can and they
demonstrate how supposed waste products
can be turned into culinary delicacies
such as the pastry called pig's ears
with plum gem my name is have big ears
instead of you know like avocados from
Spain
this Norwegian restaurant is
experimenting with seaweed coaxing
entirely new flavors from it actually
with that we are like open-minded we
pick wherever you can pick so we are not
bound to our traditions i think that is
an important thing at the market square
it's a stirring sight as the cooks
compete and the risotto world
championship
the spectators can watch and learn how
to make the Italian rice specialty as
creamy as possible four contestants have
made it to the finals the result is
something pretty simple and pretty poor
in a way because it's a poor food so I
think the risotto should be keeping very
simple very few ingredients I've been
only using the chanterelles and a little
bit of squash let's see it's a concept
the jury can swallow the nubra social
world champion is Alessandra iacoboni
who just happens to be the only Italian
in the contest asian cook shops on the
streets of the happening vesterbro
district offer Eastern Street food it
fits right in with the festival's
concept of social food two chefs from
Singapore offers simple dishes such as
egg sandwiches and noodles with shrimp
or chicken
to other chefs at the stand work in
gourmet restaurants in Singapore they
present sophisticated flavors and
cooking techniques from their country
they were invited to attend by one of
copenhagen's most innovative restaurants
the nom nom
the street food by VV will or generation
that will come into now is really going
back to basis because street food was
obviously how before restaurants that
was how it all originated at a pop-up
restaurant under the bridge
festival-goers can end the day in style
the chef's surprise that includes at
least five courses costs around 80 euros
per person beverages included
form is always a challenge is the same
as being in a normal kitchen because you
never know what happens it's like
Forrest Gump says life is like a box of
chocolates you never know what you're
gonna get it's the same thing in the
cooking business indeed true epicurean
adventures lie awaiting in Copenhagen
through this Sunday
you